hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
among the four sources of the right or
of Duty the four virtues that that
Cicero discusses in book one of on
duties we find temperance being treated
last but this doesn't mean that it's
actually the least important as a matter
of fact as we're going to see Cicero
treats temperance in a certain sense as
undergirding all of the virtues as
involved in each and every of them and
that makes sense the virtues should in
fact harmonize with each other rather
than contend so what does Cicero tell us
about temperance like each of the other
virtues it comes out of something that
is implanted in our very human nature a
drive or an inclination if you like
something that is characteristic to us
as human beings and we don't have to
worry about whether it's only
characteristic to us as human beings
it is especially characteristic to us as
human beings and so he talks about this
as a sense or way of perceiving we use
the word the verb synthetic right we
perceive we said what do we sense we
sense order or dough we sense what is
befitting what what actually belongs or
doesn't belong or what harmonizes well
in in Latin that is quid citko decades
right literally what it is that is best
or or is appropriate in those
circumstances he goes on and he tells us
that we also are the the only animal
that really has a sense for for beauty
for pulchritudinous for attractiveness
venice totem and for appropriateness for
what again fits what what is the right
thing at the right time and that is a
convent NTM and in this so this gives us
a different orientation towards the
world towards other people too
things and even towards ourselves then
other animal life has at least according
to the Stoics going with what they
understand about animals at their own
time in Chapter four and also in Chapter
five he stresses that it involves both
bodily and mental or psychical aspects
of ourselves we can think about
orderliness or beauty not only in terms
of how we speak you know eloquence or in
terms of how we how we move you know or
how our body is laid out or whether I
tie my tie correctly we can also even
more importantly think about it in terms
of our own mental acts our dispositions
the ways in which we choose and
therefore behave the ways in which we
understand the world the ways in which
we perceive things the conclusions we
you know labor our way to or or jump to
all of those fall in there he also
includes certain externals as well so
we're gonna see much later in the work
that Cicero will devote some discussion
to how you decorate and build your house
and we might think about this as
applying not just to our house or how we
arrange our books on the bookshelf but
you know our cars or you know the
clothing that we're wearing or our desk
space at work or any of these sorts of
things they can all fall under this this
basic conception of temperance involving
all of these different aspects the other
thing that he tells us and this is in
Chapter five is that this leads us to
value and to to strive for
he says Ward early orderliness and
moderation of everything that is said
and done we're in consist temperance and
self-control mode estia and temperance
iya so it really extends to every single
thing that we're we're involved with all
of it can be done in a moderate or
attempt
or consistent way or it can be done in
ways that are out of harmony with that
and and I'll pause here for a moment
just to give an example when you think
about tidying up your place why do you
in fact pick the clothes up off the
floor and put them into a basket or a
hamper to take down to do your laundry
why do you clean up the kitchen or
perhaps you don't when when you you eat
you know or put things into the sink or
the dishwasher what have you right why
is it important when you are working in
an office to actually use the trash
receptacles and to not keep your desk a
complete mess is it is it because you're
only you know doing it because of the
social pressure of other people looking
at you as being a slob if you don't or
is it because that there's something
within you that recognizes that this is
not the best way that it's better to
have some sort of orderliness can you go
on the other hand can you go too far and
have a you might say an intemperate
temperance that's certainly possible as
well there's going to be sort of a
balancing act bringing order bringing
decorum bringing appropriateness into
our existence and not just our own
existence but our shared existence with
others all right back to temperance so
another key aspect of temperance well
here we have to jump far ahead into
chapter 27 is that temperance is in fact
required for all of the other virtues to
to function and Cicero gives you a lot
of discussions he says all right we're
going to discuss the next remaining
division of moral rectitude that is in
the one the one in which we find
considerateness and self-control again
temperance eeeh at mode estia being
translated slightly different there and
he says it embraces also temperance in
the sense of here we go the the the
complete subjection of all the passions
and moderation
in all things and he says under this
head is further included what in Latin
may be called the quorum and the Greek
has called the prep own and he says this
is its essential nature it is in
separable from moral goodness for what
is proper is morally right what is
morally right is proper he says this is
at the core of of wisdom to employ
reason and speech rationally to do so
with careful consideration whatever one
does and in everything to discern the
truth that is the proper that is what is
appropriate to us to be mistaken on the
other hand to miss the truth to fall
into the error to be led astray
that is as improper as to be deranged
and lose one's mind and all things just
are proper all things unjust like all
things immoral are improper so he's
saying wisdom justice and temperance are
all interconnected with each other he
also says this about about courage he
says the relation of propriety to to
fortitude to courage is similar what is
done in a courageous spirit seems
becoming to a person and proper what is
done in a contrary fashion is at once a
moral and improper now why is it so
connected why is it so closely bound up
as he says with the other cardinal
virtues he says there's a certain
element of propriety perceptible in
every act of moral rectitude and this
can be separated from virtue
theoretically better than it can be
practically which means that if we are
actually trying to live as courageous as
just as wise people we cannot afford to
not pay attention to appropriateness to
what is befitting within particular
circumstances so this is what he calls a
general sort of propriety which is found
in moral goodness as a whole setting
that aside then what is temperance as a
specific
virtue as one of the cardinal virtues he
says it can be defined as what
harmonizes with human superiority X
Qalandia over the rest of animal life
how are we different from the other
animals now a lot of philosophers would
say oh yeah the possession of a rational
mind wisdom is how we differ Cicero is
saying well that's true but also
temperance also moderation so he says
propriety differs is how we differ they
define the special type of propriety
which is subordinate to the general
notion it is what harmonizes with nature
and what is that going to mean for us he
gives us a lot of examples here and he
actually includes in the course of this
discussion
the famous stoic four characters which
I'm not going to discuss here because
we've already got a separate discussion
of that available elsewhere what is more
important here is a discussion that
takes place at the end of chapter 28 and
the beginning of chapter 29 one which is
going to frame things in terms of two
you might say functions or dimensions of
human existence appetite or desire or
choice however you want to frame it he
says in Greek its horror may which has a
special technical meaning for the Stoics
a very broad meaning and reason or
rationality what is the relationship
between these he says the essential
activity of the Spirit is twofold
one forces appetite which impels a
person this way and that the other is
reason what does reason do it teaches
explains what should be done and what
should be left undone when things are
going properly
he says reason commands appetite obeys
that's not always the case though is it
and when we are intemperate it's a case
of appetite ruling where reason should
be the one calling the shots so he says
every action ought to be free from
undue haste or carelessness why are we
hasty why are we careless because
appetite impels us reason would say no
no pay attention to what you're doing
neither ought we to do anything for
which we cannot assign a reasonable
motive says the appetites moreover must
be made to obey the rules of reason and
notice he says two important things here
neither should they'll be allowed to run
ahead right we shouldn't allow the
appetites to be excessive and to push us
into things that you know for whatever
reason not not a rational reason but but
for whatever motive we choose he also
says that the appetite should not be
allowed to lag behind he says not from
listlessness or indolence right so there
may be cases where the right thing to do
according to reason is for us to feel a
certain way and and Cicero would say you
know we may not be successful in this
but but reason tells the appetites you
ought to be desiring this and if we do
that often enough we sometimes find
ourselves able to do this so he says
when the appetites overstep their bounds
and galloping away whether in desire
aversion or not held at hand with reason
they over leap all bound or measure they
result in a lack of temperance in
temperance in fact and this can be in
terms of food this can be in terms of
how we furnish our our houses this can
be in terms of seeking out Facebook
Likes this can be in terms of what it is
that we we say so
temperance itself requires a effort to
make reason be in charge reason is at
the core of every one of the virtues for
the Stoics and we see that it plays an
especially pronounced role here in this
entire realm of what we call the virtue
of temperance
you